احنا تكلمنا اليوم نستضيف الوجوه التي مرت
على صباح العربيه خلال العشرين عاما يمكن
مش كلهم موظفين في قناه العربيه ولكن وجوه
ارتبطت بهذا البرنامج من اشهر ضيوفنا خاصه
في فقره التكنولوجيا اسمحوا لي ان ارحب
وبحراره من القاهره الخبير التقني عبد
الله السبع ومن الرياض المؤثر والمهتم
بالتقنيه فيصل السيف اصدقائنا واحبائنا
وضيوفنا الكرام في صباح العربيه صبحكم
الله بالخير
صبحكم الله بالنور والسرور اهلا وسهلا
[ضحك]
انا مره وعلي يمكن تقريبا ست
انت مر عليك كل كل المقدمين البرنامج صح
ههه يسعد صباحكم طيب بشكل سريع احنا طبعا
نتكلم ونسترجع ذكريات ما حدث في قطاع
التكنولوجيا على مدى العشرين عام السابقه
نبدا معاك فيصل يعني كمان رؤيتك لابرز
ابرز او انطلاقا من ابرز ما حدث من تغيرات
في قطاع التكنولوجيا ما هي التوقعات
للمستقبل
جميل جدا صبحكم الله بالخير واعيادكم في
هذه المناسبه عسى دوم ايامكم خير وبركه
ولجميع العاملين والاعداد الاخت اشواق
الاخت خلود كلكم بخير وبارك الله يعطيكم
العافيه ويسعدكم لو تكلمنا عن العشرين سنه
الجايه حتلاقوا تبني اكثر لشاشات قابله
للطير هتلاقوا فعليا عندنا هشاشات اللي
لابتوباتها
بشكل جدا كويس وهذه هتسبب لنا تعدد
استخدامات اكثر ما عدا الواحد يحتاج يصير
جهازين نفس جهاز الجوال اللي موجود عنده
حتلاقوه ينطوي بشكل اقوى ولكن الشيء
المرتبط بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهو اللي حيكون
في ثوره جدا كبيره استحداث النسخ
الكترونيه لنا كل واحد فيكم قاعد موجود
الحين في نسخ الكترونيه تتعلم من محتوى
السوشيال اللي موجود عندنا وبالتالي هذا
المحتوى والتعلم اللي يصير فيه حينشئ لنا
نسخه تقوم ببعض المهام اللي احنا اساسا
نقوم فيها وتلاقوا هذه المهام اكثر قاعد
باديها الاله واحنا نتفرغ بحياتنا بشكل
افضل واحسن اتلاقوا ايضا فيه تبني بشكل
جدا كبير لا المحتوى الواقع الممزوج شريحه
ابتداء من اتوقع السنه القادمه بشكل مره
قوي الواقع الممزوج وش السالفه من نفس
النظاره حتلاقوا في اثراء واعطاء كم محتوى
اكثر فيمديني على طول وانا قاعد معكم في
الاستديو اشوف حساب مثلا كل واحد موجود
عندنا الامر حاليا موجود نظارات واقع
افتراضي زي كذا وواقع ممزوج الواقع
الافتراضي حيمكن وبكل بساطه انه احنا من
خلال لبس هذه الخوذ ننتقل الى عالم ثاني
يا بكل بساطه نشوف اضافه طبقات من
المعلومات تثري المحتوى اللي موجود عندنا
اتوقع كمان العربيه نفسها هتبدا تستثمر في
مساله المحتوى الطولي اكثر في البث
المباشر فحتلاقوا انه لما يكون عندكم
التقارير والاشياء اللي انتم تنتجوها
وتسووها بالعرض هتلاقوا ايضا مع الوقت
قاعد طبعا التحيه لكل الشباب اللي موجودين
حتلاقوا مع الوقت هذا المحتوى العرضي اللي
قاعد يصير قاعد يثرينه بشكل طولي وتلاقوا
عندكم الشاشات مو فقط في العرض ولكن فعليا
شاشه نفسها تصير عندكم بالطول هذي الشاشه
اللي موجوده بالطول حتستري كم كبير من
المحتوى وتساندكم واكيد لما نرجع لمحتوانا
الاساسي حتلاحظه المحتوى الاساسي ايضا
قاعدين تستخدموه بطريقه صحيحه ومنها العرض
والطول تساعد حتلاقوا ايضا اثراء
للروبوتات حتشوف انه في مسانده صغيره من
روبوتات موجوده عندكم
فلما نتكلم على الالات ومساندتها لنا هذه
الالات اللي حتصير تساندنا وموجوده عندنا
في منازلنا حتمكننا من استهداف امور افضل
في تسهيل حياتنا وتيسيرها باذن واحد احد
ويظل الانسان ترى هو المحور يقعد يقول
بالنسبه لي انه حيطلع عالم افتراضي مختلف
حنكون بالكامل فيه هذا امر مستسهل البشر
هم قاده هذه الكوكب من ناحيه تبني التقنيه
فما تبنوه من تقنيه هو اللي بيستمر وهو
اللي يكون طريقه للامام باذن واحد احد
وللحين الواقع الافتراضي والعوالم الثانيه
جزء بسيط من التبني واشوف انه باذن الله
تبني الاساسي لتفاعلات عن الانسانيه
البشريه ما بيننا وايضا لمحتوى باذن واحده
ما شاء الله عليه سريع في الكلام وفصيح
ايوه
على طول يعني
طبعا عبد الله السيف في مصر كيف عبد الله
السبعه عفوا كيف ترى العشرين سنه المقبله
في مجال التكنولوجيا
طيب واحده من الشغلات اللي الناس قاعده
تتكلم عنها المشكله انت طرحته علي السؤال
بعد استاذ فيصل لكن راح اجتهد بالاجابه
واكون يعني تلميذ نجيب له واحد من الشغلات
اللي الناس اتوقعها ان الجوال راح يكون من
الماضي نهائيا زي ما شغلات كثيره في
حياتنا اصبحت من الماضي لذلك المستقبل راح
يكون الاجهزه الملبوسه نتكلم عليه الساعات
النظارات وغيرها فلذلك الجوال قد لا يكون
جزء من حياتنا خلال خمسه الى عشر سنوات
قادمه طبعا هذا امر جدا صعب لكن لازم نقدر
نتخيل الحياه من دون جوال خلال السنوات
القادمه ايضا الذكاء الاصطناعي راح يدخل
بشكل اكبر كثير في حياتنا
السيارات ذاتيه القياده راح تقدر تنتشر
بشكل اكبر وايضا تقنيات التنقل ما بين
منطقه الى منطقه راح تكون مختلفه قد نشهد
الطائرات التي تتنقل داخل المدن يعني قد
يكون هناك حلول للزحمه باستخدام الذكاء
الاص والطائرات والانترنت مع توسع وجود
تقنيه ال 5 جي في حياتنا قد يكون هناك
وسائل نقل مختلفه تقلل من الازدحام داخل
المدن مثل الطائرات مثل السيارات ذاتيه
القياده وغيرها الذكاء الاصطناعي راح يكون
متواجد بشكل اكبر بكثير في حياتنا وخاصه
في المجال الطبي قاعد نشوف احنا ابتكارات
جدا كثيره تسهل على الناس امور مختلفه
تخيل انك راح يكون من الماضي انك تسافر
علشان
تعالج من مرض معين شفانا الله واياكم اي
مرض راح يكون من الماضي انك تسافر ليه
لانه الرجال الاليين موجودين بامكان اي
دكتور من اي منطقه حول العالم انه يتحكم
برج الالي ويساعدك في مرحله معينه من
علاجك فتقريبا المستقبل راح يكون مبهر
بسبب ثلاث تقنيات اللي هي الفايف جي وما
بعد الفايف جي الذكاء الاصطناعي والتقنيات
الملبو سه مثل الساعات والنظارات وغيرها
شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات المكثفه في
الواقع يعني حاولنا نركز على كل كلمه طيله
من القاهره الخبير التقني عبد الله السبع
ومن الرياض المؤثر والمهتم بالتقنيه فيصل
السيف شكرا لك واشكر ايضا معي في
الاستوديو فارس العقاد مدير الاقليمي
لمثال فيرس شكرا لوجودك معنا
شكرا